I'm gonna play a clip for you here
of Ted Cruz being interviewed on Newsmax
and you're going to hear the Newsmax
host say something that is becoming a
story about Tim Scott and it's a similar
story as it is with Lindsey Graham the
other Republican senator from South
Carolina and the way that Newsmax frames
it is that there are questions about Tim
Scott's personal life now you might be
saying what do you mean questions about
his personal life I need to be crystal
clear with you about what they mean here
they are starting to allude to the
possibility that Tim Scott is gay they
always dance around it I'll explain it
in a moment take a listen to this and
I'm and what if you're watching watch
Ted Cruz when this comes up glad for for
Tim's voice I think he's a very
important voice in the Senate and I'm
sure he will add a lot to this race yeah
so amazing life story personal story but
we don't know a lot about his personal
life and at some point those questions
will be asked as we make our way closer
to especially August the debate stage in
Milwaukee you have a comment on that oh
look I I'm sure that there will be nasty
political attacks between the different
candidates in the primary Ted Cruz is
like I know there are going to be nasty
political attacks because I'm planning
some particularly disgusting ones myself
that we can expect we've already seen
some of that uh and it's a rough and
tumble business that's that that's how
it operates okay so what are they
alluding to here I'll give you the back
story and understandably a lot of people
just haven't heard about this yet the
idea here is Tim Scott could be gay he
might be gay and the right is
speculating and the there are these
articles you know 57 year old Tim Scott
has never been married he's a sort of
Perpetual Bachelor blah blah blah blah
blah when he entered politics at age 30
he talked about being a virgin he
attributed it to his Christian faith or
something but it actually might be that
uh he's a gay man who is not
um was not comfortable saying that
publicly still isn't comfortable saying
that publicly now I have absolutely no
idea whether Tim Scott is gay there are
reports he's he's brought women to
events at times before it doesn't really
mean any anything one way or the other I
don't actually care whether Tim Scott is
gay but the fascinating part
is that the right is setting up the
homophobic line and with Lindsey Graham
it's sort of the same thing but I
actually it's not exactly the same I
don't know where it stands right now but
with Lindsey Graham it's considered more
of one of these open Secrets also a
Perpetual Bachelor Lindsey Graham and
speculation or discussions that he's
actually a gay man uh why this wouldn't
just be something you say well I think
part of it has to do with you're a
senator in a Republican party that is
still extraordinarily homophobic and
that tells you a lot about why so as far
as Tim Scott goes they are starting to
prepare that line of attack you will not
see it brought out by candidates Trump
and DeSantis aren't going to on a debate
stage if Tim Scott makes it to a debate
stage attack him for being gay it's just
not gonna happen but
the packs and the dark money Etc if for
whatever reason Tim Scott actually
started getting some Traction in this
primary which he almost certainly will
not they can start doing the there are
questions about his personal life thing
it's been done to other candidates
before that's what's being alluded to
here it's a horrible thing uh it's
probably even more horrible that it has
the potential to impact voters within a
Republican primary we will follow it and
that's what they're teeing up all of
these clips that I've been playing the
Newsmax Ted Cruz clip about Tim Scott or
the earlier Clips with Tim Scott on Fox
all of these clips we make these
available on our Instagram which you can
find by searching Instagram for David
packman show we also post them to our
Tick Tock which you can find by
searching Tick Tock for David Pacman
show and of course we make them
available on our YouTube channel if you
can find it youtube.com forward slash
not backslash forward slash the David
Pacman show we're going to take a very
short break and the show continues right
after this